hi everyone i'm priyanka ricaria
developer advocate on the google cloud
team and today i'm going to show you how
to use vertex ai and help a friend
get into yoga we are building a yoga
post classification model
let's get started first thing we need
is the data for this step my friend
sarah and i collected a bunch of images
from our yoga practice
and uploaded them into the managed data
sets
as you see here the images are labeled
in five categories
i can even upload unlabeled images and
label them
we can analyze our data set to see that
we have enough examples of each
categories
now we are ready to train our model in
here
i'm selecting automl for training method
you can also train a model to deploy
on the edge or on-premise or use custom
training
if you're writing your own custom model
code
now we define our model
automl automatically splits the data
into training validation
and test but we can change it if you
want to
in compute and pricing we get to select
how many node hours
we want to train the model at this point
we wait for the model to train
once it is trained we see it in the
model tab and can evaluate the model
[Music]
we can see our model's average precision
it ranges from 0 to 1
where a higher value indicates a higher
quality model
[Music]
we can see that the confusion matrix
helps us understand where our model is
confusing to results
now that we have evaluated our model
it's time to deploy it to an endpoint
we can split traffic between two models
deployed on the same endpoint if needed
allocate the number of nodes needed for
this endpoint
depending on where your users are select
the region to deploy your endpoint
and that's it hit deploy and we have an
endpoint
now we can test our endpoint and the
model by uploading an
image and yeah it works
you can also make predictions using the
sdk
if this has piqued your interest in
vertex ai and you want to learn more
head over to the documentation linked on
screen thanks for watching
you